Summer in the Bay of
Islands sees many yachts
visiting from overseas, so
sustoms have their work cut out for them
keeping the country’s coastal border safe.
Today they’re patrolling on
the new Hawk Five.
It’s a serious vessel, loaded with tech
and can travel at very high speeds.
So on an average
year, there’s somewhere north of 5-600
yachts and various other craft
which head down to this part of the world.
So part of our role is to go out
and make sure that those craft
that are coming this way are compliant.
With the speed
and the capability of the boat, we do have
now the ability to react pretty sharpish.
Before long, supervising Customs
Officer Nick, and his crew
get a heads up from Coastguard
that a catamaran may have tried
to sail in
to New Zealand waters under the radar.
So there’s a vessel down
in the Great Mercs
which we’ve been tasked to go
and take a look at.
Got some concerns
around the persons on board
and why they’re here in New Zealand,
and how they got here.
So probably
about ooh, five
hours away from there at the moment,
maybe a bit less.
The Coast Guard have advised Nick
the catamaran has a torn sail
and limited power.
So there won't be any kind of chase
going on this afternoon.
Last night the sailors on the vessel
radioed Coastguard for a tow to shore.
Due to rough conditions
it didn’t happen, because
authorities couldn’t board safely
to search it.
Customs on board the Hawk Five plan
to do the search now, and for good reason.
Yeah Czech nationals.
So one motor, 50% one motor out.
Catamaran’s in the past have been used
for large scale drug importations
around the pacific region.
The vessel that we’re going to now
is a catamaran by all accounts.
We want to go and see who they are
and why they’re here
and what they’re intentions are.
Make sure that they’re not smuggling
drugs, or attempting to smuggle people
or something
to that affect into the country.
Back at Auckland International Mail
Center, it's another hectic day for staff,
checking the 18,000 parcels and letters
that arrive daily.
Customs Officer Phil has pulled aside
a gift declared as cotton sheets
originating from Malaysia.
Just a little bit of shading through here.
It’s not overly convincing,
it could just be cardboard but we’ll
open it up see what we’ve got.
Inconsistencies are a red flag to Phil so
he’s onto this box like a ton of bricks.
I’ve just noticed something on the box
there “we deliver packages of happiness”
whatever that is so we’ll open it up
and see what happiness is today.
Pretty roughly packaged.
They say happiness can be found in crisp
new sheets.
It is taped here
which could be something a little unusual.
There’s this tape on here, I don’t know
whether that would be packaged
like that normally.
But these sheets don’t
make Phil very happy at all.
It just looks like a perfectly standard
piece of cardboard.
What I do notice
actually about that is it’s a bit heavy,
so we’ll chuck it on the scales.
252 grams.
That is about heavy,
I would say, for cardboard.
Years of experience have taught Phil
heavy cardboard spells trouble.
Looks to be something in there.
Looks like the packaging buried
within the layers of cardboard.
And if that's that's a drug
concealment, it's a pretty good one.